- Welcome to Maelstrom Forge.
This is where
all the magic happens.
[rock music]
First thing's first;
we've got the gaping maw
from hell,
which is my, uh,
trusty propane forge.
Use it for the--
the workhorse stuff.
And, uh, right here,
we have, uh, my grinder.
Uh, this is where I spend the
bulk of every single project.
It's definitely gotten
the hell kicked out of it,
but, uh, it's--
it's a good piece of equipment.
Next up, I've got
my big block anvil.
Just slab of 4140.
The bulk of everything
that I could ever need to do
is done just with something
with four sides.
And, uh, you know, a blacksmith
is only really
as good as his anvil,
so I have two.
I got this fancy-schmancy
120-year-old wrought
P. Wright anvil.
Uh, it does
absolutely everything
I could hope for it to do, uh,
and it's definitely served me,
uh, pretty well.
♪ ♪
- So, I'm Josh,
and, uh,
we're here
in Shobonier, Illinois,
and this is the shop
I work out of.
We got our, uh, brand-new--
as of 100 years ago--
power hammer here.
It does the trick.
It's old, but it works.
Uh, I got the five burner
propane forge.
We also got 2x72s over here.
Drill press.
We've got a lot
of hearty tools.
So, in this part of Illinois,
uh, we're kind of out
in the middle of nowhere.
There's cornfields
everywhere around you,
so if you need something,
you pretty much learn
to make it.
♪ ♪
- Here's my, uh, scrap pile.
It's got everything from
blade steels, not-blade steels.
I've even got some really
funky stuff in here.
This is 17-4.
It's a iron-based superalloy.
Uh, not good for blades.
Not good for a whole lot,
other than
jet engine components and--
and, you know, stainless parts,
uh, but I have it
in case I need it.
Uh, if I need to make
a jet engine at the forge,
uh, I've got--I've got
something to work with.
Uh, right here,
I've actually got
my, uh, favorite steel
to work with.
This is 80CRV2.
Uh, it moves like butter
underneath the hammer,
uh, responds really,
really well to the heat treat,
and--and tough as hell,
so, uh,
this is, uh--this
is probably gonna be
making that happen this week.
♪ ♪
And, uh, right here, we've got
my, uh, heat treat furnace
for--for swords,
and my quench tank.
This is an old 120-millimeter,
uh, tank round storage casing.
So this is, uh,
where we're gonna find out
if I've wasted, uh, you know,
five days' worth of work
at the forge.
Um, if I pull, you know,
something out of here,
and it's cracked in pieces,
I'm--I'm pretty screwed.
♪ ♪
- This is my, uh,
everyday carry knife.
It's kind of scratched
all to heck because I use it.
Other than smelting the steel,
this knife's all me, so.
It just kind of shows
that, you know,
I can make a knife
where the handle
is lined up the way
it's supposed to be
and I'm not under, you know,
a three-hour forging
and three hours
of, uh, handle time.
I can actually
produce something
that's actually quite nice.